اهلا بكم بعد 35 عاما من سيطره المستوطنين
تمكن عشرات المواطنين الفلسطينيين من دخول
اراضيهم في قريه برقه شمال نابلس في الضفه
الغربيه وذلك عقب قرار قضائ سمح لهم بذلك
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين
جدوى الحكم القضائي برد بعض الاراضي في
مقابل استمرار ممنهج للاستيطان
تاثير عمليات الاستيطان الاسرائيلي
المتواصله على سير المفاوضات مع
الفلسطينيين نحو 2 دنم شمال نابلس عادت
الى الفلسطينيين بموجب حكم من المحكمه
الاسرائيليه كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يرفض
تسليم تلك الاراضي لاصحابها رغم اخلاء
مستوطنه اقيمت فيها واعلنها منطقه عسكريه
قبل نحو ثمان سنوات القرار القضائي
الاسرائيلي برد بعض الاراضي يتزامن مع
حمله اسرائيليه استيطان متسارعه في مناطق
مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه ظلت موضوع خلاف
في مختلف جولات المفاوضات مع السلطات مع
السلطه الفلسطينيه بما فيها الجوله
الراهنه بعد 35 سنه من الاحتلال عاد
فلسطينيو قريه برقه شمال نابلس لاراضيهم
السليبه وكان لسان حالهم يقول بان الحق لا
يضيع مع الزمن ما دام وراءه مطالب مهما
حاول الاحتلال تبديل الانسان وتغيير معالم
الارض مساحه الارض المسترده قرابه 2000
دنم كانت السلطات الاسرائيليه قد انتزعتها
عام
1978 واقامت فيها مستوطنه حمش ثم اخلى
الجيش الاسرائيلي المستوطنه عام 2005
واعلنها منذ اذ منطقه عسكريه مغلقه ومنع
عوده اصحابها عوده العائلات الفلسطينيه
جاءت تنفيذا لحكم محكمه اسرائيليه عليا
بعد رحله طويله من التقاضي انتهت بفشل
وبطلان استئناف مستوطنين سابقين ادعوا
بهتانا شراء اراضي القريه بعد ان قدمت
العائلات مستندات ثبوتيه اكدت حقوقهم لكن
الفرحه بالعوده تذكر بجوانب اخرى
فسياسة يجد انتقادات واسعه ومتكرره على
مختلف الصعود الفلسطينيه وتعترف السلطات
الفلسطينيه بخطوره الامر لكنها منخرط في
محادثات مع الاسرائيليين برعايه امريكيه
ليزيد الامر من علامات الاستفهام الحائره
وتتواصل سياسات تهويد القدس ببناء
المستوطنات الجديده وبغيرها من محاولات
السلطات الاسرائيليه المحتله طمص الهويه
العربيه والاسلاميه التاريخيه للمدينه بل
يتم التلويح بين والخرى بتقسيم المسجد
الاقصى بين المسلمين واليهود الاحتفال
بعوده الارض ومحو ملامح الاحتلال عنها
يمثل في الواقع واحده من محطات انتصار
المقاومه الفلسطينيه للاحتلال لكن الثابت
ان اسرائيل ماضيه في تثبيت وجودها في عمق
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بالضفه الغربيه وغيرها
وتصر على الاحتفاظ بها بموجب اي اتفاق
وكان ذلك امر واقع ينبغي التسليم به
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من نابلس
غسان دغلس مسؤول ملف الاستيطان في شمال
الضفه الغربيه من رام الله اياد حداد
الباحث الميداني في منظمه بيت سالم لحقوق
الانسان اهلا بكم سيد دغلس ما جدوى هذا
القرار القضائي في ظل استمرار ممنهج
للاستيطان في كامل الضفه
الغربيه يعني نحن بالبدايه نهنئ اهلنا في
بلده برقه الذين احتضنوا تراب برقه بعد
غياب 35 عام عن احتضانهم لهذه المنطقه
التي احتلت منذ عام
1978 بموجب احتلالي قرار استيطاني بوضع
مستوطنه حومش التي تم اخلائها في خم بعام
2005 ولكن بقيت السيطره الامنيه
الاسرائيليه وبقي عوده المستوطنين الى هذه
الفتره الا ان صدر قرار الحكم القضاء
الاخير نحن بغض النظر نحن نرحب باي قرار
باي خطوه ت تعطينا شبر واحد من الارض
الفلسطينيه لان الاستيطان يستمر بشكل كبير
جدا وبشكل متسارع سواء كان بايام الحرب
بايام السلم بايام انتفاضه وغير انتفاضه
المشروع الصهيوني الاسرائيلي مشروع اي
حكومه اسرائيليه هو يرتكز على الاستعمار
في في فلسطين وهذه جزء من عمليه الاستعمار
ولكن نحن بغض النظر هناك عوده ل 1800 دنم
لاهلنا في بلده برقه والكره المجاوره نرحب
ب باستلام هذه الاراضي بغض النظر هناك 56
شهيد سقط في المرحله منذ اقامه مستوطنه
حومش على هذه الارض سقط 56 شهيد وحد الان
هناك اخوه لنا في المعتقلات مؤبدات جراء
المقاومه التي كانت تحدث على الشهر
الرئيسي وعلى مداخل كل بلده في تلك
المنطقه هو انتصار لدماء الشهداء انتصار
لاهلنا الاسرى الموجودين الذين يقبعون
الان في سجون الاحتلال وانتصار لاصحاب
الارض الحقيقيين الذين لم يفرطوا بشبر
واحد عندما ذهبنا الى المحكمه كان هناك
مراهنات ان هناك مواطنين قد باعوا اراضيهم
للمستوطنين لم نجد ذره تراب واحده قد بيعت
للمستوطنين ولكن هي كانت اشاعات للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لكي يجهد ويخفف من المقاومه
الشعبيه التي تشتعل يوما بعد يوم في كافه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه اياد حداد على ما سماه
انتصارا و بظاهره الايجابي على الاقل في
الظاهر هل هنالك مخاوف او علامه استفهام
يمكن ان تطر بمعنى انه هل هذا القرار
القضائي الذي في ظاهره الان ايجابي يمكن
ان يكون من ناحيه اخرى سلبيا بمعنى يشرعن
بقيه المستوطنات
يعني
حقيقه اضم صوتي لصوت الاخ دغلس
ب ان تحرير اي شبر من الاراضي الفلسطينيه
هو انجاز وانتصار مهما بلغ قيمه ورم يه
هذا التحرير لكن
اي عوده لسؤالك حقيقه هنالك ضبابيه
بالعاده حول اي قرار اسرائيلي واريد ان
اذكر هنا في ان اسرائيل قامت بتشكيل لجنه
ليفي قبل عام او عام ونصف وهذه اللجنه
تخصصت في البحث كيف تشرعن الاراضي الف كيف
تشرعن المستوطنات وخاصه البؤر الاستيطانيه
لطالما اي اصبح هنالك احتجاج جماهيري كبير
اتجاه هذه المستوطنات من ناحيه ورفعت عده
قضايا اي بالمحاكم الاسرائيليه والمحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه من اجل اخلاء هذه
المستوطنات فلذلك
لا لا نفرح كثيرا لان الموضوع اي قد يكون
في من وراءه هناك اي شرعنا ايضا من ناحيه
اخرى
للاستيطان سيد دغلس بالاضافه الى هذه
الخشيه من شرعنا بين
هلالين لهذا لبقيه المستوطنات من جراء هذا
القرار هل هنالك ايضا علامه استفهام تطرح
حول توقيت هذا القرار في ظل مفاوضات
راهنه يعني واضح ان انسحابهم من
المستوطنات بعام 2005 كان هو قرار حكومي
اسرائيلي اسرائيل لم تنفذ نفذت القرار
واخلت ال ال المباني ولكن لم تخلي
المستوطنين الذين كانوا ياتوا ويودون
المكان كل اسبوع ويقيمون حفلاتهم وابقت
المنطقه منطقه عسكريه مغلقه هو كان قرار
للحكومه الاسرائيليه عندما كان هناك
مرافعات امام المحاكم الاسرائيليه
بالتاكيد سنكسب القضيه ولكن ال الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وال وال في المحاكم والقضاه
الاسرائيليين يريدون ان ينزلوا عن الشجره
من اي يعني من من المواطنين الذين
يترافعون كل يوم وهناك شكاوى وهناك كل يوم
هناك قضايا ترفع امام المحاكم الاسرائيليه
هم ارادوا النزول عن الشجره لان اي محامي
كان يدخل الى قاعه المحكمه يقول لهم نفذوا
قراركم الذي ك كان بالاجماع بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه في عام 2005 هذا هو كان نقطه
ضعف في عند القضاء عند القضاه وكان هناك
يعني ترجمه بال الميدانيه باخلاء هذه
باخلاء المستوطنين وكان هناك حديث مع
المستوطنين حسب الاعلام الاسرائيلي اقنعهم
ان وخطواتهم الموجوده هنا تضعفه قانونيا
وتضعفه دوليا ولكن ال المستوطنات هناك 184
مستوطنه و176 بؤره استيطان موجوده اسرائيل
الان مستوطنين 632 ال مستوطن موجودين في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس الشريف هذه هي حقائق
مجرم حقائق كارثيه على الارض الفلسطينيه
كل يوم هناك اعمال شرعنه لبؤر الاستيطانيه
ولكن هو هو هذا هذا هذا هذا الموضوع
بموضوع كان مستوطنه حومش المخلاه كان يرهق
الاسرائيليين وكان يرهقهم بالمحاكم ولكن
انا اتكلم اليك منذ عوده المفاوضات الى من
جديد هناك 4015 وحده سكنيه تم دقها الفكر
الاسرائيلي والفكر الصهيوني هو مبني على
الاستعمار ولكن يجب ان نكون نحن في
المقابل ضد هذه ضد هذه المستوطنات هناك كل
القرارات الشرعيه الموجوده هي تدين
الاستيطان والاستيطان غير ش ولكن للاسف
اسرائيل يعني تدير ظهرها لهذه القرارات
ولم تنفذ اي منها سيد اياد
حداد اللجوء الى المحاكم الاسرائيليه يكفي
ام يمكن اعتماد اساليب
اخرى
حقيقه بالنسبه لي كناشط ومدافع عن حقوق
الانسان ارى انه موضوعه اللجوء الى
المحاكم الاسرائيليه غير كافيه
سيما وان لدينا خبره
وتجربه طويله ومرير مع القضاء الاسرائيلي
وجميعه من اعلى هيئه قضائيه اسرائيليه حتى
ادنى هيئه قضائيه اسرائيليه جميعه اما
ان يداري عن الاستيطان او يداري عن
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه او ان لا يتخذ
موقفا ااء هذه الانتهاكات هذا بالعاده
وبرايي ان هذا
الاجراءات اجراءات اللجوء الى القضاء
الاسرائيلي او المحاكم الاسرائيليه ينقصها
اولا اي توجه شعبي
بالاساس اتجاه ان يكون هنالك وقفه حازمه
من ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني والصمود في
اراضيهم والثبات على اراضيهم سيما وان
هنالك الكثير من البؤر الاستيطانيه التي
اخليت ليس بالقضاء الاسرائيلي كما نذكر
قبل شهرين في منطقه دير جرير استطاع اهالي
قريه دير جرير بالصمود بصمودهم ان يخلوا
بؤره استيطان كانت كادت ان تقوم على
اراضيهم وهنالك العديد من الامثله على هذا
النموذج اذا الاسلوب القضاء او اللجوء الى
القضاء الاسرائيلي لن لم يكون كافيا من
اجل تحرير الاراضي الفلسطينيه ودعيني ان
انوه ان
الاسرائيليين
بالتجربه يمكن ان يعطونا من الجم من الفيل
ذانه يعني ممكن الان سمحوا او اعادوا
منطقه
حومش للفلسطينيين لكن بالمقابل هنالك
يوميا نوثق كمنظمه لحقوق الانسان العديد
العديد من الانتهاكات التي تجري على اراضي
الفلسطينيين او على المزارعين الفلسطينيين
الذين يتوجهون لاراضيهم بهدف اقلاع من هذه
الاراضي والسيطره تمهيدا للسيطره عليها
اذا في هناك يعني توجه استيطاني محموم في
مقابل هذه الخطوه الجزئيه البسيطه رغم
انني لا اقلل من اهميتها فاصل قصير
مشاهدينا الكرام نناقش بعده اذا تاثير
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي على المفاوضات
المقبله مع الفلسطينيين نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش حكم المحكمه الاسرائيليه برد اراض
شمال نابلس لاصحابها الفلسطينيين سيد دغلس
الان اصبحت
فلسطين دوله مراقب غير عضو في الامم
المتحده وايضا كامله العضويه في اليونسكو
كل ذلك الا يسمح لها بالتوجه الى المحاكم
الدوليه
لتكرار تجربه مثلا محكمه العدل
عندما قالت ان الجدار وصه بالعنصري وغير
قانوني
بالمره يعني بالتاكيد
القياده الفلسطينيه هي الورقه الوحيده
التي بيدها تهدد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالذهاب الى المحاكم الجنايات
الدوليه وهذا بالتاكيد ستضطر القياده
الرجوع الذهاب الى هذه المحاكم لاننا
اسرائيل عودتنا على دائما ان ان لا تطبق
اي اتفاق ولا ولا تطبق اي
مواثيق دوليه اسرائيل تتهرب دائما وتتنصل
من كل شيء
موجود في الميدان اسرائيل دائما تنتهك كل
القوانين الدوليه ولكن هي الفرصه التي
الان عوده المفاوضات لفتره بسقف زمني لمده
تسع شهور نحن على يقين ولا طفل فلسطيني
ولا امراه فلسطينيه يثق ان اسرائيل س
تتقدم بالمفاوضات لان ما يجري في المحيط
العرب العربي بالتاكيد هو يعني اسرائيل
تقف متفرجه والشعب الفلسطيني الان وكل
الانظار العالميه والاعلام كله متوجه معنا
ما يجري في العواصم العربيه بالتاكيد هو
اسرائيل تستغل هذه الحاله الان الاستيطان
لن يتوق غير متوقف نهائيا ولكن سيد دغلس
الا يمكن الاستفاده من الورقه هذه استيد
دغلس عفوا لو سمحت لي معروف ومفهوم ان
اسرائيل لا تحترم القرارات ولكن انت تقول
هنالك مفاوضات وهذا الجزء من الحلقه يتحدث
عن المفاوضات وتاثير ذلك عليه لكن السؤال
المقصود من السؤال الا يمكن استغلال ورقه
انك لديك ورقه من محكمه شرعيه دوليه خاصه
الاستيطان يناقض الاتفاقيه الرابعه لجناب
لعام 49 يناقض القانون الانساني الدولي ه
يمكن الذهاب وجلب هذه الورقه واستخدامها
في المفاوضات لصالح
الفلسطينيين بالتاكيد انا متاكد ان
القياده ستتوجه يعني اذا فشلت المفاوضات
واذا لم يتب يتم تطبيق ق اي بند من البنود
الاتفاقيه نحن هناك عوده المفاوضات ولكن
بشروط باربع شروط منها يعني ما هي الحدود
وايضا الاستيطان غير شرعي وايضا اطلاق
سراح معتقلين وكل هذه الاجراءات التي سيتم
تنفيذها على الارض اذا اسرائيل لم تنفذ
مثل هذه الاتفاقيات بنهايه التسع شهور
بالتاكيد القياده سترفع الورقه الرابحه
وستتوجه ولكن اقول لك في شهر اذار من
العام الحالي اسرائيل منعت مجلس حقوق
الانسان من الدخول الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه
للاطلاق على ما يجري من انتهاكات
المستوطنين اذا اسرائيل مجلس حقوق الانسان
هو مجلس حقوق عالمي دولي اسرائيل تنتهك كل
الاعراف الدوليه وتمنع مجلس حقوق الانسان
من الدخول علينا انا بالنسبه لي كناشط في
الميدان ومهتم جدا بامور الاستيطان انا
اقول ال الفعاليات اليوميه والمقاومه
الشعبيه الجديه الحقيقيه هي التي توصلنا
الى بر الامان نحن كل يوم باجسادنا وبصدور
العاريه نتصدى لجرافات الاحتلال لا يريد
ان اضرب امثله كل يوم في الميدان هناك
مواجهات حقيقيه اذا كان هناك مواجهات واذا
كان هناك تمسك في الارض واذا كان هناك دعم
استراتيجي للمقاومه الشعبيه وهلنا
الصامدين في الكره والمرابط ضد الاستيطان
هناك نحقق انتصار كل يوم نصد جرافات يعني
قبل يومين كان هناك اهلنا في سرطه في
سلفيت على بعد بعد منتصف الليل صدوا
الجرافات ومنعوهم من شك طريق استيطاني وفي
بلده قسر في
منطقه س ايضا صدوا توسع
استط نحن جزء كل الشعب الفلسطيني هو جزء
واحد موحد وموحد ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
سلطه وشعب وفصائل وكل فصائل العمل الوطني
بدون استثناء
هي الايض المستوطنين ولكن دغلس اختصارا
الوقت يعني افهم منك بان السلطه لا تريد
استخدام هذه الورقه الان منعا ل انواع من
العقاب قد تمارسها اسرائيل وايضا حتى
الولايات المتحده مثل ما حصل معها عندما
انضمت الى اليونسكو
لا لا دائما
القياده ماذا يريد شعبها الش اوباما اتصل
بالرئيس ابو مازن 12 مره لعدم يحثه بعدم
ذهابه الى الولايات المتحده الفصاء
الوطنيه والشارع الفلسطيني كان يريد ان
يتوجه الرئيس الى الولايات المتحده فذهب
الولايات المتحده الى قمه سرد لم تذهب ذهب
الى قمه دمشق ذ لم تذهب اذهب الى ايران لم
تذهب ذهب اذا الشعب الفلسطيني واعي
والقياده واعيه هناك فتره اختبار لمده تسع
شهور ان لم يكن هناك شيء جدي على الارض
الارض تضيع يعني لا يوجد مكان لطاوله
واحده ان تقع فيها يكون فيها مفاوضات سيد
اياد حداد هل يمكن ان تخدع هذه الخطوه
الاسرائيليه الاوروبيين فيرون ان اسرائيل
طيبه ترد الاراضي
للفلسطينيين لا مش لهالدرجه الاوروبيين
ساذجين حتى انهم ينخدعوا بهذه الخطوه
الاوروبيين حقيقه هنالك موقف متقدم اتجاه
الشعب الفلسطيني وحقوقه العادله يعني
لمسناه في الفتره الاخيره خصوصا حينما
اتخذ قرار بمقاطعه البضائع الاسرائيليه
لكن للاسف نخشى ما نخشى ان الموقف
الفلسطيني يضعف الموقف الاوروبي اما
الموقف الاوروبي فهو متقدم ولا يمكن ان
تنطلي عليه هنالك باستمرار اي زيارات
لوفود قلت الموقف الفلسطيني يضعف الموقف
الاوربي نخشى ما نخشى
ان الموقف ال الموقف الفلسطيني الحالي اي
وهو ال الاستمرار في التفاوض بدون الوصول
الى نتيجه هذا قد يضعف الموقف الاوروبي
لكن الموقف الاوروبي كما نلمس هنالك
زيارات دبلوماسيه حثيثه وحتى ميدانيه اي
على ارض الواقع للاطلاع عن كثب في سوسا في
الغر في الشمال في كل المواقع التي تتعرض
لاعمال التهجير والتهويد وعمال الهدم
والمصادره الى اخره وهنالك دعم اوروبي
كمان متواصل لكن اذا وصل الامر الى مساله
تهديد للموقف الاوروبي كما يحصل عاده في
المفاصل السياسيه حينما لا على سبيل
المثال حينما لا يتوصل فلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين الى
اي طريق الى خارطه طريق او الى هدف معين
ممكن ان يتم الضغط على الموقف الفلسطيني
من خلال الاوروبيين لكن ان تنطي هذ لم
افهمها لفهمها تماما سيد حداد كيف يعني
يعني حو ل ت ان تشرح لي اكثر كيف يعني
الموقف الفلسطيني ان استمر بالتفاوض بدون
نتيجه يضعف الموقف الاوروبي وانت تعرف كما
قال السيد دغلس ايضا ان هنالك شرط من قبل
فلسطينيين بوقف الاستيطان
قبل الولوج الى المفاوضات ويعني السير بها
قدوما وهذا ليس شرطا حتى كما يقول سب
عريقات هو التزام
اسرائيلي هنالك هنالك اعتراف اوروبي ب عدد
من الدول الاوروبيه في الدوله الفلسطينيه
كما حصل في الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
وهنالك تزايد باستمرار في عدد الدول
الاوروبيه التي تعترف في الدوله
الفلسطينيه لكن اذا ما وصل الفل اذا ما
استمر الفلسطينيون في طريق التفاوض بدون
اي نتيجه فقط للتفاوض طبعا بالتاكيد ان
الموقف الاوروبي سوف يتغير وهذا تحتم
الظروف والمستجدات السياسيه التي سوف تطرا
لاحقا لان الموقف الاسرائيلي هو القوي
سيكون بتلك اللحظه وليس الموقف الفلسطيني
اها سيد دغلس هل توافقوا الراي هل الموقف
الاسرائيلي سيكون الاقوى علما ان بالقانون
الانساني الدولي الاتفاقيات الدوليه كلها
مفترض انها نظريا لصالح الفلسطينيين
القانون لصالح الفلسطينيين لما دائما تكون
اسرائيل هي الاقوى عند
التفاوض يعني هي اسرائيل مدعومه دائما
بالفيتو الامريكي الموجود على الطاوله
يعني هي عندما تجلس على الطاوله تعلم ان
هي مدعومه بالفيتو الامريكي دائما توصيات
القناص الاتحاد الاوروبي قبل ثلاث شهور هي
توصيات مهمه جدا وورقه التوصيات انا يعني
قراناها بتمعن هناك اكثر من 28 بند لهذه
التوصيات اقوى من بعض بعض الفصائل من طرح
هذه التوصيات مهمه جدا ويتم استغلالها
ولكن اسرائيل ليس دائما قويه اسرائيل هي
بقوه البطش وبقوه بقوه الاحتلال وبقوه
طيرانها وقوه ايضا مدعومه بقوه البطش
العالميه وبالكونجرس الامريكي منطق القوه
وليس منطق الحق ولكن سؤ قرار يدعم صحيح
سيد دغلس فقط لماذا يعني اخيرا ان اسالك
لماذا يبدو دائما الشعب الفلسطيني يسبق
السلطه في خطواته انت انت ذكرت امثله
كثيره يقفون باجسادهم امام الدبابات
لحمايه
اراضيهم اختي
العزيزه يعني واضح ان هناك احن شعب وسلطه
وقيادات وفصائل كل فصائل على المواطن هي
بخندق واحده الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن ال
احيانا الذي يكون في سلم
القياده يعني غير موجود في الميدان ولكن
في الكل متشابك الميدان الضفه الغربيه
وقطاع غزه والكس الشريف هي بقعه صغيره في
في العالم نحن نعلم بعض ونعلم ما هي ما هو
بقلوبنا الكل لا يريد ان يرى جندي احتلالي
الكل لا الكل لا يريد ان يرى مستوطن واحد
موجود في الضفه الغربيه والقدس الشريف وفي
قطاع غزه الكل يريد الوحده الوطنيه ولكن
اساليب الاحتلال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي
كل امكانياته يضخها في فقط في تفرقه الشعب
الفلسطيني الجندي الاحتلالي الذي ترون
تشاهدونه الان على شاشات التلفزه هو هو
يحمل على كتفيه اكثر من 20 1 دولار فقط
تجهيز هناك دعم كبير جستي لوجستي من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن يناصر
الظلم في العالم نحن كشعب فلسطيني نحن شعب
عزل ولكن نحن بقوه الحق وبقوه الايمان
وبقوه الاراده بالتاكيد سننتصر باذن الله
المحاكم اسرائليه وغير المحاكم
الاسرائيليه نعرف ان يعني كيف سيكون
الانصاف لحبه قمح في محكمه قضاتها من دجاج
ولكن السياسه الفلسطينيه في الميدان ومن
ومن يعمل يخطئ ومن لا يعمل لا يخطئ لك اهم
شيء ان نتوحد في مواجهه الاحتلال وقط عن
المستوطنين اهم شيء ان تعود الارض الى
اصحابها الحقيقيين شكرا جزيلا لك من نابلس
غسان دغلس انت مسؤول ملف الاستيطان في
شمال الضفا الغربيه وايضا اشكر ضيفي من
رام الله اياد حداد الباحث الميداني في
منظمه بيت سالم لحقوق الانسان واشكركم
مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد فالى
اللقاء